au delà de l'année a les nerfs mais oui
on craint montre que londres aucun mal
car salle les robots ne mentent jamais
15 2
il est libre
quelqu'un il brille ce garçon sean fait
veuillez réfléchir avant de mettre votre
vie en danger
regardez c'est en plein renouveau dirais
qu'il faut connecter qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
je crois que le contrôle
faut qu'on fasse quelque chose tu n'as
pas l'air de comprendre que les combats
cette histoire ancienne
c'est terminé attendez de voir ce que
sean sait faire
il en est sûr
il peut contrôler les robots
ça ne fait que commencer
le capturer vivant
on peut se battre
mais tu ne peux pas le cas seuls fait
venir le garçon vous ne rêvez - dimanche
et où viendrait avec moi
quand je vous aurais il avait été sur la
présence des robots
subir
tu ne peut pas sauver toute la planète
chan
vous doivent être sûrs